monsters walk among us
i might still be a monster
but i'm an evolving monster
hey guys pete here there's an official
trailer out for dexter new blood and i'm
going to give that a closer look as
there's a lot of interesting stuff going
on it gives us our first real glimpses
of both harrison and deb and overall
it's the most complete and exciting
thing they put out so far i'm gonna
break it down and i'm gonna tie that in
with all the other things we've heard
about the dexter revival so if any of
that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is your chance to leave
the full trailer builds on the teasers
that came before it revisiting and
extending some of the shots which adds
more context there's also a lot of brand
new stuff which gives us a better idea
about the story of the new season it
opens with dexter getting pulled over
while driving his truck into town
there's a knife on his passenger seat
and he looks nervous but no need to
worry it's really just his girlfriend
playing around she's the chief of police
in this fictional small town where he
lives iron lake new york which has a
population of less than 3 000 residents
you get the impression that dex who's
now living under the assumed name jim
lindsey is managing to fit in he works
at the local fish and game store he's
still the donut guy or maybe it's the
cinnamon roll guy now and he seems to be
well known and well liked around town in
the voiceover he says this is my life a
wolf among sheep from what michael c
hall and showrunner clyde phillips have
said in interviews dexter is trying to
keep his urges to kill under control and
part of that is relocating himself to
this remote place with less people and
therefore less potential victims they've
also hinted that something will happen
to cause him to fear that his dark
passenger will reveal itself in one of
the previous teasers you could see a
reflection of a victim wrapped in
plastic on a kill table as he stood in
front of a window and here you could see
he's throwing hefty bags into a fire in
an effort to destroy evidence and we
will come back to that one of the new
sequences we see is his girlfriend
angela hanging up a missing person sign
in the police station when dexter asks
her about it we get the impression that
this is a case that's ongoing and she
has no bodies no pattern someone's
getting away with making people
disappear there's a shot of a girl
hitchhiking at night she gets picked up
by a semi and you hear angela say people
don't just disappear there's always a
reason which is funny considering dexter
faked his own death so he could
disappear there's a lot of shots of him
running around looking at knives
sharpening his blades that sort of stuff
they're all mixed in there in the
background as he thinks about the
potential of someone being out there
that he could justifiably kill he's
thinking about what angela said he says
if she's right how many other victims
are there
there's a lot here that invokes the
humor of the series his awkwardness
around other people and then there's
this shot where he crosses off the date
on his calendar with a red marker and it
spills out dripping on the floor like
blood there's quite a few calendars
there there's at least six of them
hanging on his wall where you can see
that he was crossing off the dates i'm
not sure if that's to indicate how many
days he's been in iron lake or how long
it's been since he had his last kill and
you get the idea when he's looking at
the marker dripping on the floor that
he's reaching his breaking point in the
first dialogue we hear from deb it
sounds like she's addressing that same
struggle she says you're a serial killer
you love that you're getting away with
murder and you cannot wait to kill again
have you learned nothing all of this
appears to be connected to that kill and
the disposal of the body now that he
can't throw them in the ocean anymore it
looks like he burns the remains of his
victims but based on what deb's saying
i'm wondering if this is a one-off maybe
related to that shot of the police
busting into this house you see there's
a person slumped over in a chair here
who looks like he was a drug dealer i
could see this shot of dexter hitting
someone in the last teaser being
connected to that maybe this guy had
something to do with the drug dealer and
maybe that's where dex feels justified
in taking this guy out not exactly sure
how that would jive with him not acting
on his urges but we'll have to wait and
see it's a little curious because they
said they wanted to switch things up to
get out of that big bat of the season
kind of framework that they had been
stuck in but this all sort of looks like
a serial killer in town with the
addition of a kill of the week so maybe
what they're saying is that there'll be
hints of that but it won't be the crux
of the entire season
there's also some more shots at this
crime scene in the woods angela is
behind the crime scene tape looking at a
pool of blood on the snow and one of the
other cops makes a joke about dexter
being queasy at the sight of blood
there's also the first shot we've seen
of jamie chung she's taking a selfie at
the crime scene we know her character is
being described as a famous true crime
podcaster which would probably have a
pretty big social media presence all of
that makes you wonder if someone from
his old life will recognize dexter's
photo online
we also see this shot of a woman coming
out of an underground cellar to me it
looks like the same woman from the
missing poster and you see this ski mask
killer who has a rifle with the laser
scope he's popped up in the other
teasers i saw some comments saying this
character is probably based on the
serial killer robert hansen who killed
at least 17 women in anchorage alaska in
the 70s and early 80s his mo was to pick
up sex workers and take them to his
remote cabin at gunpoint where he would
rape them and then release them in a
secluded area to hunt them like wild
game before shooting or stabbing them it
looks like this might be what the
mystery man's doing as well as we see
the girl run through the snow before
getting shot it makes you wonder about
the shots we've seen of dexter in the
woods with the hunting rifle and there's
another shot of him in this trailer
where he's running in a wooded area
there's a couple of weird shots i can't
make much out of there's a person who
comes up to one of dexter's windows in
his cabin and knocks on it with a bullet
and then there's this other shot of a
kid looking through something like a
mail slot in a door as the mystery man
pulls on a ski mask we hear dexter say
monsters walk among us i might still be
a monster but i'm an evolving monster
and i can't wait to find out what he's
thinking about there
one of the most exciting scenes is deb
looking at evidence on the floor of
dexter's cabin this sort of makes it
look like she's a real person or alive
or something along those lines but the
creators have confirmed that she is in
his head similar to how harry used to be
in that capacity she seems to be looking
at evidence trying to solve the case
there's pictures of blood on the snow
similar to what we saw angela looking at
earlier you can also see these pieces of
red string at the crime scenes it looks
like that's the killer's calling card
and next to those photos there's five
photos of people you see dexter and
angela and then three new characters
clancy brown who's playing kirk caldwell
the owner of a local truck stop who is a
sort of unofficial mayor of the small
town what looks like this guy who shows
up a little later in the trailer with a
rifle and some blood on his face and
this other guy who we saw waving a knife
around kind of joking about it at
dexter's job
in a final scene that follows the title
and the release date dexter comes into
his cabin and finds a teenager inside
looking at his stuff when he asks him
what he's doing he finds out it's his
son harrison
they did give this away a couple weeks
ago they confirmed that it was harrison
and that he would show up in the first
episode and what's crazy about seeing it
is how that's going to work with
everything else that we've already seen
in my last video i talked about how
clyde phillips told the tca that there
wasn't a way to go back and revisit
dexter without including the theme of
fathers and sons and so here we get a
look at their reintroduction now it
would probably take a whole another
video to get into all the different
speculation about how this might work
how harrison figured out he wasn't dead
how he was able to track him down in
upstate new york how old is he really
because he should only be about 13 years
old and they're obviously aging him up
some here but as far as this video is
concerned you could see that his
presence is going to make things even
more complicated in dexter's life and
that's all the big stuff we see in the
trailer when i was looking at what
people were talking about after it
dropped i noticed some people wondering
if deb was really alive or if maybe the
kid in his apartment is someone else
pretending to be harrison unless
everyone involved with the show is
willfully misdirecting us then i don't
expect either one of those things to be
the case they've said in multiple
interviews that deb is essentially
taking harry's place and that dexter and
harrison coming back together as a main
focal point of the season they also said
they weren't changing anything that
already happened and deb definitely did
die in the finale it all looks great
this trailer especially looked pretty
impressive and it contrasts so well with
the old setting in miami and the old
dexter each new thing they put out
increases my interest in revisiting this
character i think i probably will put
together a harrison video because it's a
little hard to say right now how well
that's gonna go over out of everything
that we've seen it's the one thing that
feels like it might not work at this
point but i suppose the idea that they
have they thought it was essential and
they thought it was a good enough reason
to bring the series back the rest of the
new characters all look pretty
interesting
i like the idea of bringing someone in
who has a platform obviously this
podcaster might be looking into the
trinity killer and considering that rita
was one of his victims that might make
an exciting situation i mean she
wouldn't be in upstate new york for that
it looks like she's probably coming for
this new killer but you can see how any
attention from her or her followers
would be potentially awful for dexter
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you thought about the new trailer what
you're hoping to see what are your
theories please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching i'll talk to you soon